I just got a phone call from my agent
and he said there's a show called
Breaking Bad they're going to invite you
to do a part you've got to say yes to
this one this is the kind of part people
win Emmys for I'd never seen breaking
bad it was in its second season and it
was not doing well in the ratings didn't
really do well until the third and
fourth Seasons so Vince calls and he
goes it's a character his name saw
Goodman he's got he's a lawyer he's a
sleazy lawyer you see these guys on the
back of buses they have the little
advertisement on the back of the bus I
said I know we barely know each other
I've not read anything but I have an
idea for his hair I said can he have a
comb over and a mullet and then clean on
the sides and Vince goes ah I think
that'd work that sounds pretty good the
look of Saul is a big part of how I play
them and where I draw the energy from
what you two need is an honest to God
businessman right well I haven't worn an
Emmy yet but I've come close so my agent
was pretty on the nose there he knew
what he was talking about